es momento de hablar de economía en
france24 pero yo me acompaña en el
estudio mi compañera daniela blandón
daniela buenas noches bienvenida
iniciamos con el mercosur los líderes
conmemoran 30 años del bloque y la
reunión se centró en peticiones de
apertura comercial o la valentina buenas
noches se supone que iban a celebrar
pero las tensiones por el tema comercial
fueron el plato fuerte del encuentro
virtual entre los presidentes de los
países que conforman este bloque que son
brasil argentina paraguay y uruguay así
como chile y bolivia que son países
asociados la principal divergencia tiene
que ver con la apertura comercial que a
la mayoría de estos países les gusta
bastante pero no a argentina porque
prefiere reforzar su propia industria el
presidente de este último país terminó
incluso de palabras con su homólogo
uruguayo escuchemos obviamente que el
mercosur su actividad su producción pesa
en el concierto internacional lo que no
debe ser y no puede ser es un lastre
nosotros no estamos dispuestos
a que sea un corset en el cual nuestro
país no se pueda mover si nos hemos
convertido en otra cosa en una carga
lo lamento no queremos ser lastres de
nadie si somos un lastre que tomen otro
barco pero lastre no somos de nadie
valentina recordemos que mercosur es la
quinta economía mundial y promueve que
haya libre circulación de bienes y
servicios entre los países pero diversas
voces lo acusan de estar estancado en
parte por estas disputas internas entre
sus miembros
bueno pues cambiamos de tema y ahora
hablamos del bloqueo del canal de sus
tres días bloqueados deja pérdidas
millonarias diarias sí y valentina un
estudio de la aseguradora alemana
allianz señala que mientras el
gigantesco buque permanezca varado en
plena vía marítima que conecta a europa
y asia el comercio mundial pierde entre
6.000 y 10.000 millones de dólares por
semana
el incidente alteró las cadenas de
suministro globales para todo desde
granos hasta ropa para bebés y generó un
trancón marítimo de más de 230 barcos
usted se lo puede calcular valentina la
primera consecuencia es que se
duplicaron en apenas tres días las
tarifas de envío de los camiones
cisterna de combustible y eso tiene un
efecto directo sobre los precios del
petróleo y los combustibles las
autoridades del canal siguen trabajando
para desencallar el portacontenedores
que recordemos carga unas 224 mil
toneladas de productos
daniela pues preocupante nos alejamos de
esta atención en el canal de suez y
citibank está estrenando presidenta si
se llama james fraser y se convirtió
hace pocas
en la primera mujer presidenta de un
gigante bancario the wall street pero lo
más llamativo es que llegó para aliviar
la fatiga causada por la pandemia y por
el teletrabajo su primera orden
valentina fue prohibir las videollamadas
los viernes pues cree que la pandemia
les ha quitado tiempo a los trabajadores
también animó a sus empleados a que
tomen vacaciones en un mensaje interno
les dijo que comprende que citigroup es
una empresa que opera a través de los
husos horarios pero también que cuando
el trabajo se extiende a las noches de
manera regular a las primeras horas de
la mañana o incluso los fines de semana
eso les impide recargar baterías y
concluye diciendo que esto no es bueno
ni para ustedes los trabajadores ni para
citibank
dice ella estas directrices llegan días
después de que se publicara en las redes
sociales un documento de jóvenes
reclutas de goldman sachs en el que se
quejan de las largas jornadas de trabajo
y del elevado estrés de recomendaciones
que deberían aplicar muchísimas empresas
en el mundo vamos con los indicadores de
la jornada o 70 con récords en sus dos
principales índices el dow jones de
industriales-
standard poor's en europa hubo alzas y
fue noticia en alemán ya que el club de
fútbol brujas suspendió su salida a
bolsa prevista para este viernes y en
américa latina hubo movidas leves en los
principales mercados finalizamos con la
cifra del día 563 mil 400 dólares
valentina por ese valor se vendió una
columna del diario the new york times a
través de una plataforma nfc en la que
justamente se trata este fenómeno
conocido como token criptográfico esto
es un objeto virtual que gracias a la
tecnología la misma de las cripto
monedas queda registrado como único e
inviolable en una plataforma virtual
esto quiere decir valentina que no se
puede replicar y que todos los derechos
de ese activo quedan en la nube daniela
muchas gracias por este análisis por
toda esta información y a ustedes
gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
nosotros que hay más aquí en france 24